start off by talking about the dream
he's really quick because I know you're
a part of a big push to get women more
included in the music industry what did
you make of Grammys night watching the
women just really sweet you know what I
wasn't I didn't watch it because I was
pretty I was presenting at the BAFTAs in
London but I'm so happy for cardi and
all the women had killed it that night
and I'm so proud happy for Alicia she
did an excellent job so I you know I
hear so congratulations Alicia the
graduation party congratulations
everybody all the women we need the full
force of the Academy bingo
now tell me about cha cha because she is
awesome
it's just really like SiC her she's a
she's a sociopath she's crazy um she
loves hazel because we hope he helps
they kill people and she just loves
she's a business woman she loves to
murder she's all about her business she
stays focused on the business the
business is to assassinate this person I
love watching you in this role what was
your favorite part about playing her and
did you get to do some of that awesome
stunt work my favorite part about cha
cha is her shooting the guns I love
shooting the guns and I love fighting I
learned martial arts yeah so I'm doing a
lot of the stunts for me thank you so
much